well diving into a swimming pool on a
day like today can certainly be
refreshing but when it comes to the cost
of maintaining the pool of course not so
much as heather mills reports inflation
supply and low stock continues to plague
pool owners but the question is is there
an alternative
the price of chlorine is up 20 to 30
percent from last year as the nationwide
shortage continues now into its second
year but not all pools use chlorine
there are some advantages to using salt
water temperatures are soaring but so
are the prices to keep your pool up and
running what used to be
20 30 dollars for a jug is now 100 130
140 150
chlorine both liquid and tablets are not
only more expensive but also harder to
find as the nationwide shortage
continues
cliff maltsman owns a pool company he
says it could be a while before things
are back to normal it's caused partly by
a supply problem because the nation had
most of its chlorine made at one
particular plant in louisiana and they
had a they were damaged by hurricane
laura in 2021 they were supposed to be
back online in 2022. now that's been
delayed until 2023 the other factor
driving demand more people bought pools
during the pandemic construction
increased 25 percent in 2020 but
maltsman does say over the last several
years more people have also switched to
salt water you can't taste the salt in
the water but we do put a certain amount
of salt in the water and then there is a
a machine that comes with the pool
that transforms that salt that's in the
water
into chlorine if you're looking to
convert it's the initial cost that will
add up a couple thousand dollars and
then you never have to buy chlorine or
chlorine shock annually the cost of salt
water tabs will be less than a hundred
bucks and you can compare that to
chlorine which could cost as much as
eight hundred heather mills live local
now